[Music]
welcome back to an amazing day two of
Google cloud next wasn't yesterday
awesome today we have a really packed
agenda and we're gonna try and pop
yesterday with great great new
announcements and lots of product areas
in yesterday we talked about our vision
as Google for cloud computing to give
you global scale distributed
infrastructure a digital transformation
platform and Industry specific solutions
that facilitate digital transformation
today we have a packed show I'm going to
start off talking about some new things
we're doing an infrastructure and
security talk about data management
smart analytics advances in AI and
machine learning what we're doing in
collaboration and Industry specific
solutions to kick off today let me
welcome
Orsola senior vice president technical
infrastructure orce
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning every day Google cloud
connects to over a billion IP addresses
all over the world not for Google but
for GCP customers and those bits travel
on our network and 99% of the time they
get handed off directly to the last mile
is peace so we can control security and
performance all the way now our scale
has taught us that we can always do
better two and two more to help our
customers succeed and that thought
guides us at Google when we think about
capital investments when we think about
product priorities as Thomas and
cylinder sundar underlined yesterday
we're spending an enormous amount of
capital and human resources to build out
that vision thirteen billion dollars
just this year just on data centers just
in the US and of course there's more so
there might be better forms of hardware
for machine learning there might be
advanced admission data centers better
data storage smarter analytics so we're
committed to bring a lot more clouds to
you not just in our data centers but
also in your data centers we believe in
a cloud with a lot less hassle cloud is
too hard today and it's our job to make
it simpler through easier policy
management through consistent api's
through open software open source
software that works where you need it
and that's the guiding principle between
the cloud services platform which we
announced last July to manage containers
and services both on-premise and on GCP
and just eight months later yesterday we
announced the final product anthos and
simply put I believe that anthos is the
future of cloud it's a big statement
why because anthos is a single platform
that lets you develop secure release
monitor operate debug your services its
mature its robust it has advanced
functionality even today so the stack
the ANFO stack includes container
orchestration service management config
and policy management DevOps tooling and
a robust marketplace as he saw yesterday
so that customers can have an unified
experience when they consume the
products and services of independent
software vendors and it works equally
well for your existing as well as new
software so you don't have to rewrite to
get the benefits and of course it works
wherever your teams are working and last
but not least since its fully managed
even on-premise you don't have to worry
about operating and updating that
platform so you get a cloud experience
in your data center as well if you want
to know more I invite you to join the
ask me anything session tomorrow morning
at 9 o'clock there were also lots of
sessions yesterday that you can recap on
video now customers started using the
CSB beta several months ago and now are
starting to use anthos in production and
a feedback has really been excellent
they're working faster with fewer
impediments and more freedom and because
it's based on open source it's a safe
choice for years to come it's not a
single vendor choice so that's why I
believe that anthos really is a great
choice for the cloud strategy of any
enterprise and with anthos we're making
hybrid and multi cloud the new normal
you see that in our new traffic director
which seamlessly balances your traffic
across both on-premise and
GCP instances and soon across instances
in other clouds as well it works for
both VMS and containers it routes
traffic over our backbone so your
application gets unparalleled resiliency
of that network or take our approach to
soloist computing so functions you know
the ability to run code without managing
VMs or containers Cloudland a new
product that you'll hear a lot more in
this afternoon's developer keynote
combines the speed and ease of use of
service computing of functions with the
flexibility and portability of
containers so you can use any language
in any runtime in cloud functions not
just what your vendor happens to provide
and of course it's based on open source
ok native and it will be part of anthos
so it will work everywhere you want it
to work
now the cloud isn't just about deploying
and managing applications it's also
about data and one of TCPS biggest
strengths is to help you do more with
your data you can ingest the integrate
analyze predicts both with traditional
analytics and with machine learning and
of course we offer a cloud platform with
natural language understanding that's
built in both into your apps and into
our apps so that's a purposeful AI like
like an assistant for your call centers
or for your enterprise for a better
customer or employee experience so we
make AI accessible not just as
technology and tools but also as
solutions and that's also true for our
collaborative applications you'll hear
more a later reducing G suite teams
communicate and deliver faster so you
get better workforce engagement and
better productivity
there's always up-to-date documents for
example with live commenting
there's video conferencing that just
works and there's AI to boost your
productivity in spreadsheets documents
and email but now let me turn to
security because we know that no company
can move forward and serve its customers
without the greatest trust in the
Alliance reliability and security of the
platform that it's running on and at
Google security is really something that
we've built in from the start
comprehensively it's not something
that's folded on later in as Thomas
mentioned yesterday a little bit we
start with the principle that your data
is your data and only your data it's the
lifeblood blood of your company and no
one should access it without your
knowledge and consent not Google not
vendors that you engage not employees
that you don't want to have access and
we're the only cloud that offers access
transparency products that's access
transparency logs for virtually all of
our products that document such
administrative access in near-real-time
we also provide powerful data security
tools like the data loss prevention to
discover and classify sensitive data
wherever it is and we have VPC service
controls it's a new feature that allows
you to segment multi-tenant resources of
cloud services to mitigate data
exfiltration exfiltration risk so it
allows you to combine the benefits of
and strengths of such managed storage
without expectation risks and so it
combines those those services with the
security of a private truly private
cloud and you can only get them on
Google cloud in fact you'll see 30 more
announcements at just next that are
related to security so I can't mention
them all but I'll call out just a few
more here
our cloud security command center
provides a single view of all of your
cloud assets buckets VMs containers and
their risk profile and an event threat
detection lets you is that is a new
service that we're introducing that lets
you spot signs of compromised or
malicious activity in your logs and last
but not least policy intelligence is
something I'm very excited about
it's a machine learning basic service
that gives you the confidence that he
actually specified the right set of
access controls and that you're not
accidentally giving overly broad access
to people now while it's critical to
secure servers and services we also make
it easy to secure your users and end
devices as part of an end-to-end
strategy first Chromebooks are the most
secure and easy to manage enterprise
laptops on the market period because you
have no OS patching them no backups to
worry about like we do all of that and
with Hardware verified boot in every
single laptop they're virtually immune
to virus attacks we also developed
security keys now an industry standard
to help protect accounts from phishing
and to make strong authentication as
easy as touching a security key because
we want as many users as possible to
take advantage of that today we're
announcing a software security key that
will work in most Android phones so soon
a billion users will be able to take
advantage of it and secure their
accounts like never before so let me now
briefly show you how all these security
features work together for end-to-end
protection protection so let's assume
you're taking an existing application
and you're moving it into an tha's on
premise or in the cloud doesn't matter
it's the same so you immediately pick up
all the built-in security
of anthos like strong service identities
and cure encrypted communication between
services centralized policy and config
management you get that out of the box
and then by putting our identity of
where a proxy in front of it you now get
single sign-on with security key second
factor for this application and you can
configure further context of our access
policies for that application and if you
have business customers you can use
Apogee API management to expose services
to other businesses in a b2b setup all
of that without touching your
application your existing application
and since anthos has centralized audit
logging all those log can be fed into
bigquery or event threat detection to
give you critical insights about this
setup so it's a simple consistent way to
modernize not just the application but
modernize your security posture and move
to a zero trust model now all of this is
built in close coordination with our
customers and partners as you've seen a
growing list of some of the world's
largest enterprises and we're really
honored to have their trust now while
there are many new features that were
announcing today they're all part of a
larger single consistent vision a cloud
platform that's uniquely built around
open standards with production great
code so you pick your environment on
Prem or in the cloud and you don't have
to change a thing and you see that
commitment to uptime and to reliability
in the Google cloud as well in fact
recently two leading third-party
research firms published their findings
about 2018 cloud reliability and I want
to say this research was neither sponsor
nor influenced by Google but GCB
demonstrated by thank you TCB
demonstrated by a substantial margin the
highest reliability of the three major
close meet three major clouds it's not
even close so to wrap up a Google cloud
we're investing a lot in security and in
your future right you can see that
really throughout all of today's
announcements and of course you get
great reliability and great security on
GCP and you reduce the complexity of
your IT so that you can move faster so
thank you for choosing us as a partner
for your journey to a simpler more
secure naturally hybrid cloud thank you
and now back to Thomas Thank You ORS in
addition to security we at Google take
you as customers and your trust in
Google extremely seriously one of the
issues we want to address at the
conference is the issue of privacy and
our stance on it it's very simply put
your data is your data and no one else's
your AI models are your AI models and no
one else's
no one at Google will access your data
without your permission we do not have a
backdoor to allow any agency to access
your data without your permission you
can
the data at rest or in transit into a
cloud you can use your own encryption
keys to encrypt that data if you want
Google to help you access that data for
a support purpose we will stream in near
real-time the logs of every operation
our people are doing to help you with a
support request no other cloud provider
provides you these facilities and for us
that's a measure of providing you the
comfort and trust that Google will never
ever use your data for any other purpose
outside of delivering you the service in
GCP that you're using
now one of the key areas that people
wanted us to provide great technology
for is the area of data management we
offer a number of solutions for data
management - rehearsed enterprise
databases in our cloud to help you
migrate databases from on-premise data
centers to our cloud and great new
solutions to build new scalable
applications using the broad portfolio
of assets that we as Google provide for
data management today we're going to
show you how to move Microsoft sequel
server Windows and Active Directory to
our cloud there are many other
capabilities were introducing in data
management to show you that with a
demonstration please welcome deep-tissue
Rostova from product management
Deepti
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Thomas I'm excited to be here
today to talk to you about databases
which we know are a critical part of
your business Google cloud offers a wide
portfolio of database services for
transactional operational and analytical
workloads
all protected from threats by advanced
security we know it can be challenging
to build new applications and to bring
existing workloads to the cloud that's
why we are committed to providing a
first-class experience to you as you
move to Google cloud including for your
Windows workloads so let's take a look
here we have a typical Windows app
adventureworks just like many Windows
applications this one runs in a virtual
machine and uses sequel server as its
database back-end you might have
thousands of Windows applications from
small simple ones like this to large
critical applications running in your
data centers to help lift and shift
windows workloads to the cloud Google
cloud provides tuned windows and sequel
server virtual machines images you can
bring your existing licenses and run
them on sole tenant to stay in
compliance or buy licenses through us
now let's turn our attention to sequel
server our cloud sequel managed database
service offers support from my sequel
and Postgres today I'm excited to
announce that cloud sequel will offer
fully managed Microsoft sequel server
later this year thank you
it works with all your familiar tools
but better because it's fully managed
this gives you and your teams the
opportunity to focus on building what's
next now let's modernize this window
adventureworks
app starting with the database using
sequel server management studio we'll
take a full backup of the sequel 2008 r2
database used by this app will simply
run the command in SSMS to generate the
file once completed we can upload this
to our Google Cloud Storage bucket
we've already uploaded the generator
file to the appropriate bucket as you
can see in the console here next we'll
restore the backup to in cloud sequel
for sequel server will select them
managed instance we've created select
import and select the DAAD back type
from here we'll then find and select the
GCS bucket where we've uploaded the file
type in the database name and select
import to initiate the restore once the
restore is complete all we have to do is
copy the IP address and just change the
connection string in the configuration
file for the application that's it we
can refresh and now our adventureworks
app is up and running on manage sequel
server for the latest version of sequel
server
Thanks so to recap cloud sequel for
sequel server is a fully managed
database service that handles the
mundane tasks of operating a database
for you so you can spend more time
innovating but we know that sequel
server isn't the only critical part of
the windows ecosystem Active Directory
is the standard for authentication and
authorization in Windows environments
today you can run Active Directory
yourself on GCP and federate ad users to
GCP with cloud identity our Identity
Management Service but we wanted to
enhance this experience for you so I'm
happy to announce that managed service
for Microsoft Active Directory will be
coming later this year to GCP this new
managed service runs actual ad domain
controllers and makes it easier for you
to migrate your directory dependent
applications and servers to the cloud
just like with our managed sequel server
service your IT and security teams can
focus on higher value tasks by spending
less time on server maintenance and
security configurations you can keep
your user and password data on-premises
using methods like one-way force level
trust while allowing users to
authenticate against the managed service
in the cloud for lower latency and geo
veil ability here you see us logged into
SharePoint running in a GCE VM that is
domain joined with managed Microsoft ad
as you can see the user identity still
originates from on-prem Active Directory
so we now have sequel server and Active
Directory running as managed services on
GCP these services work with your
familiar tools this will help you focus
more on delivering higher value
experiences for your customers and
employees instead of managing and
securing infrastructure manage sequel
server and manage Active Directory are
coming to GCP later this year now let's
take another look at what's always on
everyone's mind security
to help secure your windows workloads
GCP provides defense in depth
we offer shielded VMs for Windows and
Linux which are hardened by a set of
security controls that protect
enterprise workloads from threats like
remote attacks privilege escalation and
malicious insiders this is a simple
checkbox item when creating your VMs
this is just one example of the tools
you have at your disposal to help secure
your workloads we covered a lot of
topics this morning so let's recap you
want to spend more time delivering
innovative products to your customers
and less time managing infrastructure
and security you can do this by choosing
manage services and advanced security
for your Windows workloads on GCP thank
you and back to you Thomas
[Music]
Thank You Deepti to talk about their
experience using Google cloud please
welcome Justin Arbuckle from Scotiabank
Justin
welcome tell us a little bit about
Scotiabank you're you're ten times older
than Google and a 200 year old Bank tell
us a bit about your business and how
you've been a market leader for so long
well we're Canada's most international
bank we're in over 50 countries and we
have a strong retail presence in both
Canada and the Latin American markets
which allows us to balance the stability
or the financial services environment in
Canada as well as this incredible
innovation that we have in in the Latin
American markets you know over the last
few years we've opened a number of
innovation centers are digital factories
and I'm pleased to say that at the
moment we have over 25% of all of our
global retail transactions running off
of a digital platform that runs on the
cloud thank you how are you approaching
your transformation at got your bank
carefully you know the the the thing we
have to realize when we talk about
transformation is it isn't bimodal you
can't transform half of your
organization and not the other and so we
don't have a bimodal transformation
strategy we want to have a unified
transformation digital transformation
for our entire organization and so for
this we have to reimagine how we build
applications for the cloud to be a cloud
first Bank and to do this we've built a
platform called Plato and Plato of
course runs on Google and what Plato
gives us is the ability to be far more
responsive to be high velocity and I'm
again happy to say that in the next few
years we'll be able to be migrating 40%
of our applications globally to the
cloud on Plato you know data plays a key
role in banking hmm you're doing some
amazing stuff can you tell the artist a
little bit mobile more about what you're
doing yes I mean you spoke about privacy
before customers give us their data and
they trust us with it and Trust is a
critical part it's the core of our
business
and so looking after that data is
important and we take that extremely
seriously but also we need to be able to
use that data the PII data and
transactional data etc to be able to
create complex queries that allow us to
give customers the kind of service and
experience that they need and that they
want as well as manage bank risk and so
we are moving our data to a global data
platform that runs on Plato and what
this allows us to do is be far more
responsive again to our customers and to
manage the quality of the data that we
actually are using to make these
important decisions but you know also
something that we have to remember is
that that data fundamentally is the most
important asset that we have and so the
same platform Plato is also providing a
real-time data stream of all of our
transactions globally and what that
allows us to do is do some really clever
things with anti money laundering fraud
etc just as a final couple of points
we've just like to say if you don't mind
Scotia bankers around the world or
wearing pink today to celebrate the
International Day of pink which is to
celebrate the fight against homophobia
transphobia and all other forms of
bullying I hope you join me and then
finally I would just like to say and I'm
sure all of my speakers here would agree
we're up here we get to be up here
because of the incredible teams that are
behind us some of mine are in the
audience some of them are back home just
like to say thank you thank you very
much Esther much thank you so much
[Applause]
another part of Google's platform that
many many customers around the world use
is our analytics foundation people
historically have used us for three
important reasons
first they want to do real-time
streaming analytics looking at data
coming in real-time streams to the cloud
second they use us to augment and
enhance their enterprise data warehouse
using bigquery and third they use us to
run Hadoop and spark clusters without
having to run and manage them themselves
today at Google cloud next we have some
amazing new capabilities in an analytics
foundation it's predicated on three
important things first
to allow you to use AI models and auto
ml to automatically categorize data and
do predictions so that a business
analyst can use AI as part of their work
second we've introduced a number of new
capabilities to make it much easier to
move data into our cloud third we've
enhanced bigquery with even more
features and a new capability called bi
engine to retain its performance scale
and computational advantages we're also
grateful for a number of partners who
have worked with us to integrate their
tools and technologies width our
analytics foundation so you can use your
favorite ETL tool your favorite
visualization tool your favorite
metadata management layer and to show
you some of these advances please give a
warm welcome to Julie price a big data
specialist in Google cloud Julie
[Music]
Thank You Thomas hello everybody
now I'd like for you to think for a
second about the last time that you sat
at home eagerly awaiting the delivery of
a package now I want you to think about
the incredible amount of data that goes
into ensuring that millions of packages
are delivered as expected across the
globe each and every day baby needs to
be pulled together from so many
different places often in siloed systems
both internal and external
that's what Cloud Data fusion is all
about it's a fully managed and cloud
native integration service it's being
announced today it's got a broad library
of open source connectors of sorry open
source transformations and over a
hundred out-of-the-box connectors for
all sorts of systems and data formats
let's take a look at how data fusion
shifts an organization's focus away from
code and integrations to insights an
action so all of our shipping data is in
an on-prem system and we want to move it
into bigquery so we can further analyze
it and combine it with other data this
is incredibly easy to do with data
fusion here we've defined our
on-premises connection and we can see
all of the tables that are available we
can simply type in to select shipment
details if that's the table that we want
to see and so if we click on it we can
see the data in the table and decide
what type of transformations we want to
do so let's go ahead and do a simple
transformation and delete one column we
could do far more complex
transformations all through this UI
we're gonna keep it very simple for this
demo now we operationalize the pipeline
by clicking on create and we're gonna
set it up as a batch pipeline now that
we've created the pipeline we need to
define where we want to land the data so
if we want to load the data into
bigquery we just drop the bigquery
connector as the endpoints and connect
it to our transformation step that's it
that's all we have to do and now we can
deploy and run this pipeline so we've
manually run this pipeline but of course
you can schedule your pipelines you can
also have them triggered and now if we
head over it's a big query we can see
that we've got all of our data low
and ready to be analyzed as we've
deployed and run this pipeline in
advance now you've just seen the hell
with a few clicks we can create a
pipeline to move data from an
on-premises system into the cloud
without writing a single line of code
and as a quick reminder organizations
across the globe love using bigquery to
perform analytics analytics at scale
because it's completely serverless folks
can focus on insights rather than
infrastructure and operations bigquery
also allows enterprises to continue to
use their existing bi and dashboarding
tools like tableau liquor click and
Google Data studio and with our shipping
data in bigquery and ready to go we'd
like to be able to monitor our global
operations and make very quick decisions
that's why it's a day we're announcing
the bigquery BI engine the AI engine is
the native bigquery accelerator that
enables you to visually analyze and
interact with your data at the speed of
thought all with incredible scalability
and security it's now available through
data studio and we've got other byte BI
partners coming soon so let's have a
look at our shipping data and data
studio dashboard that's powered by a bi
engine now right away we can see that
there's something going on with Brazil
it looks like Brazil has significant
delivery delays but packages that are
shipped from Brazil aren't necessarily
responsible for as much revenue now with
each and every click on this dashboard
we're visualizing and processing
millions of rows of data with sub-second
response time all things to BI engine
now if you're in charge of logistics at
this company you've got to figure out
what's going on in Brazil so how would
you do that many folks would use
spreadsheets to perform this type of
analysis but we're talking about
millions of rows of data so that would
be impossible in any spreadsheet
environments but not in connected sheets
connected sheets is a new feature of G
suite that's being announced today it
brings together the power thank you
connected sheets brings together the
power of bigquery with the familiarity
of the existing Xi's products so let's
head over to sheets so we can take a
look
here we've got she's connected to our
shipments a tonne dataset in bigquery
and with the bigquery data in connected
sheets we could take advantage of
traditional functionality like charts
pivot tables and functions but across
the entire bigquery data set so we've
got over a hundred million records in
our dataset but connected sheets can
process billions of records let that
sink in for a second now what's really
awesome as well is that you'll be able
to accelerate connected sheets with the
BI engine that we just talked about so
let's go ahead and look at our summary
dashboards tab now what you can see here
is a number of standard functions that
are referencing a combination of
bigquery data and data that we've
entered into the sheets so you can see
we're using the input map min and max
distance on the left that we've entered
into sheets to calculate averages across
data that actually exists in our
bigquery data set what we really wanted
to look into Brazil shipping delays so
let's move over to the country breakout
tab now here we're using standard pivot
functionality but again across our
entire a bigquery data set we're slicing
and dicing the on-time delivery percent
by country and the number of zones at
each package cross and it looks like
packages are getting delayed even when
they don't leave Brazil so there might
be something going on in the country
that we need to look into now we can
share this analysis with folks in Brazil
using standard collaboration
functionality common ontology suite
products our colleagues in Brazil
determined that the delays were due to
highway construction and a simple update
to the routing software will take care
of those issues so let's take this one
step further since we have the data in
bigquery how about we use this data to
predict which routes might be
problematic in the future so we can make
adjustments and ensure that the packages
get delivered on time as you heard
earlier thousands of enterprises are
already using bigquery to store and
analyze up to petabytes of data every
company wants to understand and use
machine learning but not every company
has access to ml experts and that's why
today we're also announcing Auto ml
tables
automail tables will enable anybody that
knows data in your organization to
automatically build and deploy
state-of-the-art ml models and increase
massively increased speed and scale so
let's jump over to auto ml tables and
take a look here you can see we've
connected to our bigquery data set and
on the right hand side you can see the
full Tabas table schema that auto ml is
pulled in and on the left you simply
decide which column contains the field
on which you want to train your model
and this becomes what gets predicted
when you feed future data in that's all
you have to do you don't have to be an
elmo expert we didn't write a single
line of sequel or tensorflow code Auto
ml tables will find the best model for
you so let's move over to the predicts
tab now it's a save time for the demo
we've already trained the model and once
the model is trained then you can easily
run it against new data by configuring
the input data field so we're pulling
the data from bigquery the new data we
want to feed in and then you can feed
the resulting predictions back into
bigquery for further analysis and
visualization so let's have a look at
that in data studio now we can augment
our bi with AI we can begin to enhance
our historical dashboards with
predictive insights so the stash board
might look pretty familiar but our map
is now showing the predicted delivery
delays instead of historical and since
we solved some of the issues in Brazil
with rerouting around the construction
now we can focus on where we expect the
next delays to come in which as you can
see are predicted to be in India now all
of this was done with just a few clicks
and no code allowing you to move from
raw data to predictions in no time so
you've just seen some of the amazing new
additions to Google clouds fully
integrated and serverless platform cloud
data fusion bigquery bi engine connected
sheets and auto ml tables will make it
easy even easier for folks across your
organization so quickly and seamlessly
turn data into mission-critical insights
with that thank you and I'd like to
welcome Thomas back to this
[Applause]
Julie showed you a logistics example
using our analytics foundation a real
customer in this business that all of
you know and love is United Parcel
Service to talk about how they're using
Google cloud to transform their business
please give a warm welcome to Juan Perez
chief information officer of UPS all
right good morning everyone at UPS every
day we solve a challenge of epic
proportions how do we efficiently
deliver 21 million packages every single
day and by the way this challenge grows
even bigger during our peak time around
the holidays when we deliver more than
32 million packages a day the question
is simple what is the best most
efficient and most profitable way to do
it well we have just a few ways to
deliver just one route by the way if
you're really curious about it the
number of possible solutions to deliver
one route at UPS is 199 digits long but
in every case at the end only one route
is the best route we address this
challenge head-on taking our data
analytics practice to the next level we
design routing software that tells the
delivery driver exactly where to go
every step of the way during a hundred
and twenty pickup and delivery stops in
any given day and by the way it even
accounts for the most important thing of
all and that is taking that very
important lunch break this software
saves UPS up to four hundred million
dollars a year and it reduces our fuel
consumption by 10 million gallons a year
that quite frankly it's the power of
analytics at UPS
and using these as a foundation we've
determined that the power of our data
opens significant opportunities to
continue to improve our operations and
most importantly our customer service
today with support from partners like
Google cloud we're creating the ups
smart logistics Network a combination of
experience expertise and technology
powered by real-time data that
transforms our physical assets into the
world's most integrated Network this is
not just simply when drivers are
delivering packages on the road it's
also the loading docks
it's where we sort packages at ups
everything behind the scenes but gets
that package delivered that one package
to your door stop on time every day
data plays a key role in the smart
logistics network at UPS forecasting our
package volume levels is critical to
running an efficient Network let me tell
you how we leverage bigquery for the
most precise volume forecasting in UPS
history we gather and analyze more than
a billion data points every day
including package weight shape the size
of our packages as well as the location
the facility capacity we have across the
network and customer data Google
technology allows us to perform
analytics on this massive
data set while providing the platform
and the capability to run machine
learning different models across all
this data the outcome for us is really
critical the outcome of the forecast
tells us exactly how to load our
delivery vehicles how to maximize the
use of our assets and how to ramp up our
network around the holidays most
important of all it helps us make more
targeted operational adjustments
minimizing the forecast uncertainty that
comes with the unforgiving demands of
e-commerce the more real-time data we
can get about the state of a package the
better visibility we can get into
potential challenges
and ultimately the better we can serve
you our customers it truly is a brand
new day for a smarter more agile and
ultimately a more forward-looking UPS
our future follows a path paid by
prescriptive analytics that's where
we're going which allows us to achieve
true supply chain visibility and
efficiency in moving goods between 220
countries and territories faster than
ever imagined we are grateful for the
opportunity to collaborate with great
partners like Google in a way that lets
us use our joint expertise to bolster
visibility across supply chains around
the world thank you again for the
opportunity to be here Google has
invested many years of work in AI and
machine learning we have focused on
building an AI platform that provides a
very deep understanding of a number of
fundamental kinds of data voice language
video images text translation on top of
this platform we have built a number of
solutions to make it easy for our
customers and analysts around the world
to build models one example being auto
amel where the software itself helps you
build a model and finally to speed how
companies and organizations can use AI
nml to transform their business we're
delivering a number of business
solutions that can be very quickly
adopted and can change how your
organization uses AI and ml to run its
business to explain a number of new
advances
that we're announcing today please
welcome Rajan shchet from our product
management organization for AI and ml
Raja
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Thomas so we believe that AI
will transform every business in every
organization over the course of the next
few years and our goal is to empower all
of you to be able to transform along
with us and we're seeing it happen over
and over again with big businesses and
small businesses alike this is a
testament to the power of AI but it also
reflects our commitment to deliver that
power to everyone in your organization
whether they're builders or business
users or business decision makers so
let's start with the builders builders
are everyone from machine learning
experts all the way through developers
who are just getting acquainted with AI
for the first time and if you're a
builder you're on the forefront of AI
you're facing the most complex
challenges and solving problems in a
brand new way and we've spent years
working to understand your needs and
we've used those insights to build the
most sophisticated platform for AI
development anywhere so today I'm
delighted to announce our Google AI
cloud AI platform the AI platform is
what happens when every step of the AI
development process meets the best of
Google everything from robust end-to-end
machine learning pipelines from data all
the way to the fruited production to
things like samples and tools for
everyone hosted Jupiter notebooks and a
hosted environment to make deployment
and management of machine learning easy
and importantly we believe that
empowerment means giving you the most
flexible hybrid clouds so you can deploy
machine learning in our cloud on-premise
on other clouds and at the edge and this
is made possible by what we call coop
flow an open source framework for
running AI anywhere the kubernetes runs
and can be managed by anthos we've also
added the AI hub which is a one-stop
shop for all of your AI resources it
allows you to reuse pre-built ai
resources from a raw a wide range of
sources and also share your own
solutions with then within your
organization in addition to that we're
committed to making it available for
more and more developers to be able to
access AI
as Thomas mentioned Otto Amell is really
doing this Auto LML makes it easy for
you to be able to create machine
learning models on your particular data
set now when we introduce Auto ml last
year we made it easy to do things like
image classification natural language
processing and translation and make it
accessible to everyone regardless of
technical expertise Auto ml is the how
one of the highest quality and simplest
solutions anywhere for building custom
machine learning models and training
them on your own data and this year
we're delighted to introduce two new
members of the auto ml family Auto ml
video in Auto ml tables which extend the
power of auto ml to video content and
structure tabular data so now to
demonstrate what builders are capable of
we've invited one of our biggest and
most ambitious cloud AI customers to
join us so please welcome up beanie
Mathieu head of digital products for
Baker Hughes ge
[Music]
hello I'm beanie Matthew and I'm the
head of digital products for Baker
Hughes a GE company I run a team of
developers and data scientists that work
to create advanced analytic products to
solve complex industrial problems at a
massive scale for our customers
predominantly in the oil and gas
industry we work with Google Cloud for
this very reason our AI based solutions
developed on the Google cloud give us
the scale and flexibility to build our
analytics models and of course on the
deployment side it gives our customers
the choice to deploy on the Google cloud
platform so combined with the other
Google technology we use such as cube
flow at pipelines for managing
end-to-end ml workflows kubernetes and
tensorflow for deep learning
capabilities we view the Google
relationship as very strategic in the
oil and gas industry so what are we
trying to solve in the oil and gas
industry one of the most persistent
problems we saw we face is something
called non-productive time and
essentially this means that machines
shut down and that sounds simple but
it's not often for the reason you would
think there's a system of machines
connected to more machines and those
systems are connected to more systems
and the problem is usually in
interaction between these thousands of
machines and non-productive time can
mean millions of dollars lost if not
more and the way that this has been
addressed in the past is not scalable
you've often had an engineer modeling
data in a spreadsheet or an operator
relying on past experience instead of
real time data and so Baker Hughes's
cloud-based AI capabilities can now
analyze hundreds of terabytes of data
and at the level of entire systems and
continuously learn unsupervised from
normal behavior that significantly
increases the accuracy scale and
predictive power of our models and gives
us a much better chance that system
issues that results in non-productive
time can be found in advance and
circumvented entirely now that also
takes significant computation which
Google Cloud easily accommodates by
fluidly scaling across GPUs and GPUs are
critical to AI and for our customers
this kind of rapidly scaling AI means
fewer machine
problems safer operations less downtime
and money saved thank you thank you be
new it's amazing to see what a
difference a I can make when builders
think big but what if you're a business
decision maker and what you care about
is how this can make a difference for
your key business goals you can benefit
from ai2 which is why we're offering a
growing range of AI solutions to help
solve some of your most pressing needs
business decision makers can benefit
from AI with a variety of different
types of solutions and I want to talk to
you about three that we're that we're
introducing today so first we're
launching what we call document
understanding AI which helps
organizations automatically extract
insights from documents but also make
your business processes easier this
could be from everything from things
like invoice processing to identifying a
content within contracts to many many
many other other use cases and so for
instance Commerce Bank is working with
our launch partner Iron Mountain to
explore ways that this can help simplify
as GDP our compliance for HR we're also
looking at challenges faced by specific
industries and we're starting with
retail and for retail customers today
we're launching what we call
recommendations AI and the draws upon
Google's deep experience in
personalization to deliver product
recommendations at scale and we've seen
some pretty amazing results so far with
revenue on recommended items increasing
by as much as 50 percent for some of our
first customers and finally I want to
talk to you about contact center AI
which makes it possible to scale phone
support without compromising the
customer experience it's virtual agents
can automatically help callers with the
most common tasks but in addition it's
agent assist tool can automatically feed
information relevant information and
workflows to human agents for those more
complex calls and it's based on dialogue
flow which makes it easy to build
intelligent chat BOTS that can answer
questions and perform tasks through
natural language
now one thing that's important is we
want to make sure that this integrates
into what you already have and so what
we've done this we've integrated this
with the top telephony providers and
contexts and their providers in the
market so this should just insert
directly into what you have today
without rip and replace so to talk a
little bit about what we have I'm
excited to welcome up Sarah Patterson
senior vice vice president of product
marketing and strategy from Salesforce
and Karyn Van Kirk VP of viewer
experience
[Music]
thank you Thank You Sara and thank you
Karen for coming for coming to Google
next well so I want to talk a little bit
about what you're doing and so sir can
we start with you and can you tell us a
little bit about Salesforce service
cloud absolutely thanks Rajan so I've
been at Salesforce for a little over 10
years and it's developers and IT leaders
like everybody who is here today and
everybody who's watching online you have
really been our lifeblood
you've actually made service cloud the
market leader because you've taken our
platform and you've used it to help your
companies differentiate their offerings
with service services becoming your
brand and now our customers are asking
us to make it easier to deliver great
service using intelligence which brings
us to the partnership between Salesforce
and Google cloud absolutely and we're
really excited about the work that we're
doing together and in fact today we're
announcing that partnership with
Salesforce service cloud to build the
contact center of the future so can you
tell us a little bit about how you're
using Google cloud ai technologies
Google cloud allows us to accomplish two
powerful goals first chat box that we
all know and love
they provide a really great way to help
companies to engage with customers and
scale your support without scaling your
costs and we call our AI powered chat
BOTS Einstein BOTS we wanted to give
them a fun little name service cloud
users can now bring Google's dialogue
flow into Einstein box to augment our
natural language processing capabilities
and add in Google's extensive
multilingual support we're also excited
to announce that we're integrating
Google's contact center a I was service
cloud phone
believe it or not is still one of the
primary channels for support and by
combining contact center AI with our
ecosystem for telephony partners service
cloud users can now elevate their phone
support all through the interface
interface that they're already familiar
with that sounds great and so Karen can
you give us
more about how this is making a
difference at Hulu sure Hulu is one of
the largest streaming services with over
25 million subscribers in the US and
we're growing really quickly that growth
is great of course but it brings
customer support challenges as well a
big part of our solution is a
partnership with Salesforce and 5/9 with
technologies like chat pods but even the
best bot it's not a replacement for
humans so that's why we offer phone
support as well and we really believe
that AI is the next logical step to
bring it all together and that's where
Google's contact center AI comes in it
improves the customer experience because
each call will start with a conversation
with a virtual agent or other than
fumbling with a phone tree and it will
make our human agents more productive
because knowledge articles and workflows
will surface real time based on what is
going on during the call and finally
we'll have better data quality and
analytics we can monitor language and
sentiment real time to fight incidents
and then we can also dive in to better
understand what is driving customer
satisfaction these are amazing
capabilities and so can you give us an
example of how this helps the could the
customer experience in ways that you
haven't been able to do before
customers will often mention a show
they're interested in watching and that
can be a great signal for the agent to
know how to work with them for example
suggesting a change to their
subscription plan to better meet their
needs
so let's say a customer is thinking
about adding live TV to their account
and they happen to mention an interest
in basketball aging assist can
automatically recognize the topic and
surface information to the agent to help
them have a better conversation with
that customer perhaps a reminder that
the NBA playoffs are about to start from
there agent assists will surface
personalized recommendations and the
workflows needed to make the change to
the plan that's incredible it seems like
a new level of customer engagement yes
with service cloud and contact center AI
will be able to improve that customer
experience and drive efficiency at the
same time and we're able to empower
everyone here today to build the next
generation of service experiences right
thank you both for joining us
really appreciate it thank you so you
know for a long time building AI
products has seemed like bringing things
from the future which often seemed like
science fiction and bringing it to the
present day but these stories really
show you how a AI is making a difference
for customers today the future is now
and so let's go make it happen together
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
many companies are using AI today to
transform their businesses when you go
back home think about how AI and our
technology can help you change your
business now 15 years ago fifteen years
and nine days to be precise Google
launched a product called Gmail was
launched with a very simple premise
every human should be able to do mail
from wherever they are all they need is
a browser today that product is used by
over one and a half billion people every
day we believe however were poised for
the next wave of change in collaboration
our vision is very simple enable
collaboration for everyone in the world
not just white-collar workers but the
2.2 billion people in the world who are
called frontline workers nurses pilots
aircraft technicians repair workers all
of whom now have a digital device called
a smartphone allowing them to
collaborate from everywhere using the
devices they have using all of their
senses they share go to speak to people
instead of having to type see things
using the camera instead of having
to always enter things on just text they
should be able to collaborate in context
and using AI we should be able to
augment how they collaborate we have an
amazing new set of capabilities in G
suite to show you that and explain our
vision for it please welcome Amy Loki
vice president user experience for G
suite Amy
[Music]
hi everyone it is fantastic to be here
with you all today I leave
user-experience 4g suite and i'm excited
to talk to you today about how we are
elevating human accomplishment and
helping businesses transform the way
they work I love working on these
products because it's incredibly
rewarding for me and my team to hear
from our users that we help people
accomplish their most important goals
with our cloud native collaborative
tools G's suite is comprised of apps
that over 1.5 billion people use like
Gmail Docs sheets and drive and it
includes solutions specific to the
enterprise like hangouts meet and chat
we also provide solutions for students
and educators and I'm excited to show
today that more than 90 million students
and faculty are using G Suite for
education today more than 5 million
businesses use G suite and this includes
digital innovators like Netflix Spotify
and lyft who built their businesses with
G suite and continue to scale with us
today more traditional enterprises like
Verizon Nielsen and Carrefour the need
to adapt to a changing landscape also
turned to G suite companies with large
frontline mobile workforces are
increasingly turning to G suite so for
example AirAsia uses G suite to connect
air crews air crews flight operations
and ground staff helping to improve
their on-time performance these
customers are turning to us because they
know that this transformation provides
tangible business impact
according to a recent Forrester total at
economic impact study customers moving
the G suite saw on average 1.5 percent
top line revenue growth as well as
efficiency improvements equivalent to
saving each employee one month of time
these are just a few examples of
businesses that are reimagining how they
work so let's dig in on
geez sweet empowers teams to make it
fast make it smart and make it together
here are some examples first make it
fast teams need to be able to move
quickly whether it's responding to a
customer request or getting a product to
market we've built AI into G suite to
remove repetitive Monday and work that
gets in the way the Google assistant can
now help people get more done at work
the same way it can on the home at home
or on the go I'm incredibly excited to
announce today that the assistant will
be able to access your G suite calendar
so you can see what your day looks like
and stay on top of any schedule changes
let's try it out hold on hold on
okay Google what's next on my calendar
today next up you have G suite spotlight
session today at 11:00 a.m.
awesome but I might be running late
coming from this keynote okay Google
tell the meeting attendees to save me a
seat in the front row here's the message
to the attendees do you want to send it
or change it looks good let's send it
okay
your message was sent to the attendee
okay how cool is that
time for the applause great next let's
talk about how G suite helps teams make
it smart with cheese suite
everybody has better access to the
knowledge and the information and people
that helped them make well-informed
decisions
two years ago we introduced cloud search
which brings the power of Google search
into your business we also offer it as a
standalone solution so that even
businesses who have not yet adopted G
suite can harness the power of Google
search today I'm excited to announce
that we are making third-party
connectivity in cloud search available
to eligible G suite customers cloud
search will now index data sources like
s AP Salesforce and SharePoint in
addition to G suite enabling employees
to search and find
to every digital asset and person in the
company finally G suite helps teams make
it together individual contribution is
almost always one piece of a larger
puzzle that requires multiple people to
solve last year we introduced hangouts
chat our messaging platform built for
teams I'm incredibly excited to share
with you today that we are bringing chat
into Gmail so that all of your team
communication can be in one place now
now from Gmail you'll have the people
the rooms and the threaded rich content
right at your fingertips now I've gotten
to use this for a couple months
internally and I have to say it has
changed how I communicate everything's
easier it's more efficient and I feel
much more connected to my team now as
much as we rely on chat and email
sometimes the easiest way to connect
with people is just to pick up the phone
I'm excited to share today that voice
the cloud telephony service built 4G
suite is now generally available thank
you voice gives each employee a phone
number that works from anywhere on any
device and it's easy for admins to
manage and provision and with our
text-to-speech technology it's easy to
set up a welcoming interactive menu to
greet the people that call your business
now Thomas and I have both talked a bit
about how G suite connects frontline
workers to the back office to accelerate
access to data and information but what
does this look like in practice let's
take a look at the retail industry this
is inspired by how we see our customers
using G suite today so this is Frank
Frank is a store manager at a national
apparel chain he's had three customers
asked for the same sneakers in one day
so he realized that these shoes must be
hot but Frank is worried his store is
losing sales because his shoes are not
in stock so Frank logs into a shared
Chromebook
tablet from the store floor he jumps
into chat and he pings a room with other
store managers to see if they're
noticing the same thing
Frank quickly confirms the other stores
are experiencing the same spike in
demand well it turns out a YouTube
celebrity recently sported the issues
setting off an instant trend but
unfortunately they don't stock these
shoes on the west coast with chat Frank
in his community of store managers feel
engaged and empowered to influence the
company's strategy Frank and his
colleagues quickly set a heads up to
corporate using Google forums their
input is immediately captured and
visualized in sheets enabling
headquarters to quickly detect the issue
and adjust their distribution strategy
while retailers have a lot of data on
the products that they stock and sell it
is hard to gauge customer demands for a
product that's not on your shelf which
creates a blind spot with cheese sweet
Frank and his colleagues on the store
floor can share this valuable data that
might have otherwise been missed back at
headquarters the team uses hangouts meat
to quickly reach a decision on how to
supply these sneakers and as we watch
their meeting in a moment you'll see
that features like live captioning a new
capability that's important for
accessibility makes it easy for a
diverse group to participate let's check
it out
good morning everyone
it looks like customers on the west
coast are looking for a new sneaker that
we don't stock there Katie are you
seeing this near stores as well yes I'm
definitely seeing this across my 10
stores these shoes are on fire I've
pulled the latest inventory data from sa
P into this sheet let's see if any
warehouses are overstocked we can pool
product from
fortunately it looks like we have a ton
of stock in the Midwest I'll run the
numbers and work with our partners at
UPS to get that shipped ASAP great
thanks for the quick work everyone
as you saw artificial intelligence in
sheets means that employees can analyze
data through a conversational query and
data can be easily pulled in from
databases like bigquery and s AP teams
across the retailer from the store floor
to headquarters were connected and data
moved instantly enabling the company to
quickly get these shoes on to the feet
of West Coast customers like myself so
in closing I'll leave you with this
quote from one of our customers a TV
financial that's pretty incredible
after moving to G sweet nobody at a TV
financial would ever go back because
it's changed who they are G sweet is not
only a catalyst for elevating the way
that your team's work together and
accelerating their access to information
it's an investment in your people and
your culture I'm excited to see you make
the jump to G sweet and I am confident
you will never want to go back thank you
thank you a company that made the jump
to G suite and has decided never to go
back is whirlpool would you all give
Michael hime chief information officer
whirlpool a warm welcome to Google cloud
next Mike
[Music]
it's clear that Google Google clouds
helped me drive it was hypershade hat
thank you Mike you're an early
enterprise customer of G suite what made
you decide to join Google Cloud well we
started our implementation in 2014 but
the story really goes back before that
we were emerging from a general
recession in our business we saw
tremendous innovation on our product
pipeline and we really had the ambition
to get that product to market faster
that required us to change the way we
work the way we engineered across our
global engineering centers and we
embarked on a mission partnering with
our friends in HR and our colleagues and
facilities to renovate our buildings
change our culture and then put in put
in place a new productivity sweep to
underlined all that we call that
strategy the winning workplace and it
was really about we put our consumer in
the center and it was really all around
how do we live differently digitally and
then how do we work differently
digitally so that whole strategy really
began to drive our thinking around what
is the right platform and we got we got
a little bit crazy not only do we want
to change consumer experiences but we
want to change our business partners
experiences with us and we conducted we
decided to conduct a series of tech
fairs we brought in three competing
products and we let our business
partners come in our colleagues and
trial essentially kick the tires on
these products and see which they might
like and overwhelmingly they chose G
suite what's been the effect tremendous
I would say the the way in which we have
driven collaboration productivity inside
our environment everyone is just
thrilled is the quickest way to say that
and maybe it may be a couple stories of
what people can do on these products we
have a plan in Mexico to build a whole
productivity visual dashboard around
plan operations on their own in G suite
we got tremendous support and if you if
you haven't been in these products and
you don't understand the challenges of
versions versus no versions yeah you
have to really try it so we had we had a
one of our best supporters is the CEO is
executive assistant she was tired of
presentations coming to the executive
committee or going to the board changes
revisions how you keep all those things
current and she really drove now we're
gonna do it one way we're gonna do it in
Google we're gonna set that up and when
you're when you're done you're done and
the beauty of these products is there
are no revisions when you're operating
and the same when you see an error you
fix it when you're operating on those
platforms when you're done you're done
we also had another example where we
acquired a company about our same size
as our European business we needed to
integrate them quickly and the first
step in that integration was first to
give the team managing the integration
the tools that was very early on our
deployment and then we very quickly
brought that whole business if you will
into our business and made them part of
our family and when you can collaborate
that way and share in that fashion you
really increase the speed at which you
can get things to market that's amazing
what else have you got plans for and how
else have things changed you know we we
chose one of the big reasons we chose G
suite and Google we believed we would
get a constant stream of innovation and
clearly you've seen that again this
morning and we've benefited from that so
we've not plateaued we started our
journey in the 14 we're five years in
we're still growing we've got tremendous
additional productivity through your
next mile program we thank you for that
and we see just a continuing opportunity
to drive the way in which we work and to
change that is associated with that so
and maybe you know a second one I'll
just mention thee this was our first big
push towards the cloud and both for the
enterprise for business partners and and
for the IT function what we have done is
a result of that and the success that we
have experienced it really emboldened
our strategy to go cloud first and from
that moment till now we've got over 80%
of our workloads in the
while and that really all started with
the success that we drove from G suite
thank you so much Mike it's wonderful to
have you so the last piece of our
portfolio specific solutions to enable
digital transformation in specific
industries one of our important assets
at Google is geo and to show you how
companies and enterprises are using geo
to transform their business
please welcome Jen fitzpatrick senior
vice president geo at Google
[Music]
good morning everybody I'm happy to be
here to share with you today what we've
been up to in our geo work at Google for
more than a decade now we've been
mapping the world and translating that
knowledge and understanding into
meaningful experiences for our users
we started many years ago by mapping
roads so we could help people reliably
get from point A to point B but over
time what we've seen is our users
showing an appetite for more and more
types of knowledge and understanding
about the real world they asked us more
and more complex questions and they've
fully expected maps to be able to
provide helpful answers her experiences
in new types of contexts so we set off
to deepen our understanding of the world
to bring new types of knowledge and
understanding to the map as well as more
dynamic and real-time content the real
world changes fast and keeping up with
the pace of that change can be a
challenge but in recent years advances
in technology have helped us get smarter
about the way that we build maps using
the power of machine learning and what
we know about the world through things
like imagery and user-contributed
content we're able to keep Google Maps
fresh accurate and real-time for more
than a billion users all around the
world let's take a quick look at how we
do that we use machine learning
algorithms to look for changes in
satellite imagery which allows us to
automatically detect new roads based on
this approach over the last nine months
we've added half a million kilometres of
new roads in more than 20 countries with
a similar technique we can automatically
detect and draw a building outlines
which has allowed us to more than double
the total number of buildings on the map
around the world in less than a year we
continue to push the bounds of what it
means to map the world and to have an
incredibly rich and up-to-date data
model now what does this have to do with
all of you Google Maps platform is the
means by which we give our enterprise
customers access to the same rich and
complex real world information
that we use to power our consumer
products this is long been an area of
focus for us in fact our original Maps
API czar well over ten years old what we
see happening today is a real
acceleration in businesses finding new
ways to use location and real-world
insights to transform their customer
experiences as well as how they operate
let me share a few examples
transportation has always been an
obvious area of focus for us given our
core emphasis on helping people navigate
the world and as the transportation
industry continues to transform we're
partnering with many different players
from automakers to ride-sharing to
public transit in the automotive space
we've partnered with automakers for
years to bring information from Google
Maps into cars but in recent years we've
begun going deeper partnering with auto
companies like Volvo and Renault Nissan
Mitsubishi to bring a fully embedded
voice driven Auto tailored version of
Google Maps and the Google assistant to
the car and we're really excited to see
the first cars with this new experience
hit the streets next year but really
this is just the start cars are quickly
becoming more connected and are
gathering larger and larger volumes of
sensor data so whether it's making sense
of to leverage telemetry data from cars
or spotting part performance trends or
helping manage in-car machine learning
and compute we see many ways that we can
partner together ride-sharing is another
industry that we partner closely with
today we power more than 800 million
routes each day for customers like Ola
DeeDee go Jack lifts my taxi and more
beyond just navigation though we're
helping to provide insights that can
drive real-time decisions and
optimizations for their vehicle fleets
so operations get more efficient and
riders and drivers can have a great
experience we're excited to keep
innovating with our partners to unlock
even more benefits of the transportation
industry as well as for cities and
public transit agencies all around the
world the information that we know about
places business is on the map and points
of interest all around the world
great opportunity for enterprises of
many types let me share a few more
examples last year we introduced a
tailored solution for the gaming
industry letting game studios use the
power of Google Maps to build real world
games creating virtual game worlds based
on real-life locations or creating
gameplay in the real world based on
masses knowledge of where the best spots
to play are the game stir you mix II was
an early customer and partner for us
here and when they added a real-world
experience to their already successful
game monster strike they saw a 30%
increase in daily sessions per user and
this experience isn't unique to gaming
as the world has gone mobile
location-based capabilities are
repeatedly transforming customer
experiences across a wide range of
industries the travel industry is
another area where knowledge of real
world places is absolutely critical to
success and so we're working with travel
booking sites to add our deep
understanding of places directly into
their customer experiences servicing the
right information about what places are
nearby when someone's trying to make a
decision can help drive conversions and
turn casual explorers into real
customers these are just a few of the
many innovative ways we see our
customers taking advantage of Google
Maps platform now many of my examples
today have been about enterprises using
Google Maps platform to provide better
experiences for their customers but
we're also working with companies around
the globe to provide real-world insights
that help drive operational efficiency
from retail to insurance to finance and
more we're helping with things like
where to best target your promotional
spend where to best locate your next
door front and many many more things
beyond so no matter what industry you're
in location-based data and insights can
have a powerful impact on your business
and today more so than ever we encourage
you to think about how you can use the
power of location to transform your
business and with that I'll turn it back
to Thomas
[Applause]
so we at Google are using our cloud to
bring the best of all of Google's
technologies to enterprises now one of
the industries that we've had a long
history of working with is healthcare
our mission is to help organize
different kinds of information that
healthcare providers need electronic
medical record information genomic data
information clinical trials information
to help organize it so that providers
life sciences companies and others can
use that information in new ways to take
care of patients and prevent disease one
of the customers that we've been very
fortunate to work with is Mikasa and
please welcome Andy Sydney chief
technology officer of McKesson to Google
cloud next Andy
[Music]
[Applause]
and II thank you for coming we're very
excited to have you with us tell us a
little bit about how your IT
organization is solving your key
business problems yeah first of all
thanks for allowing my cats gonna be
part of Google nag so we do appreciate
it for for McKesson Google clouds much
more than the technology right for us
it's more about the culture and what it
brings to the table of not only the IT
but truly the the the culture of Google
to the table we're a hundred and eighty
year old company we've been dealing with
suppliers partners customers for 180
years it's critical for us to take a
look at the emerging technologies and
how we change the way we do business and
what we deliver to the workforce it's my
job to take a look at the emerging
technologies that we can bring in for
the business and enable them to deliver
its speed it's more important now than
ever and if you take a look at the
technology that Google cloud brings it
fits that space and allows us to deliver
at speed several years ago McKesson
started a journey looking at what we
should do moving to the cloud we
partnered with a few people few other
companies and it looked at selling our
data centers getting rid of some of the
legacy equipment and really forcing the
move to cloud services to eliminate a
lot of the complexity that an on-prem
data center gives you our existing cloud
strategy was a lift and shift that
really wasn't getting the job done for
us after four years we look back we
didn't make the progress that we really
thought we should have at that point in
time so we had to look for a new partner
and once again that's where Google came
in and Google cloud in the meantime we
were running an analytics projects
looking at pocs and those two
conversations sort of came together
looking at reinventing the
infrastructure but then the google
analytics platform to
Google it became a parent really
understands healthcare they understood
our business the inter store stood the
regulatory and compliance issues and
complications that are brings it brings
a customer focus to the table plus we
need to move faster and Google really
brought that culture a move with speed
and engineering mindset to the table
well that sounds like a strong signal
yeah it was really interesting for us
right Google came to the table and made
us forget everything that we knew
basically tore up and blew up all of our
processes challenged everything that we
did and brought a software engineering
mindset to the table and an automation
first mindset there really made us
rethink Google's been around for a long
period of time now it's not a start-up
anymore but they still have that move at
speed and move with agility mindset and
that really made us start to think we
can do different things the work
approach that Google that Google brought
was really a shift in our culture Google
cloud became a natural contender for our
major shift in transformation projects
they competed well by showing up much
differently than the others and it
really comes back to that culture and
mindset of moving with speed and
enabling the business through the
technology to be honest with you at the
beginning I think my team was taken back
by Google's approach because it wasn't
just the lift and shift the team seemed
a little bit frustrated from a partner
coming to the table and telling us we
needed to significantly change the way
we were delivering and think differently
the leadership view that as an
opportunity to change things
significantly much faster than we had in
the past we looked at it as maybe we
should be stepping back thinking more
like a software company a software
engineering company as Google is it's
not what we were doing at the current
point in time are incumbents we're
telling us lifting shift was the way to
go
make it a car saving initiative that's
not the case right Google said reinvent
yourself make yourself better we sent
the engineer teams back out we met with
our pairs we met with Google engineers
and it became very clear Google was
winning a lot in this space not just
small accounts but large enterprise
accounts pretty quickly the resistors
that were in the teams
sort of gave in saw what we could do for
the company and really how much IT could
shift from being a back-office function
to a differentiator for the business my
director of strategy Trevor always says
you know we want to shift IT from being
the people that just maintain technology
to be in people and a team that is
driving differentiation to the business
and enabling them deliver product at
speed that means the move the cloud for
us and a cloud architecture needs to be
put in place so that we can deploy
features faster continuous deployment
continuous testing and deliver and fix
security across the board in a seamless
manner right and abling that speed once
again this moves us from below the line
low value-added services in IT to above
that line and delivering value to our
business and not just business as usual
that's a great outcome thank you so much
for your partnership and thank you for
coming to Google Nexus preciate it
thanks Randy
if you're a media company or
telecommunications company Google can
help you with audience acquisition media
asset management media archiving
streaming infrastructure and the ability
to reach consumers directly not only
have we built technology for the
industry we're also very proud to
announce today a partnership with
Accenture announcing an intelligent
from our engagement solution for a
number of industries using Google's
platform let's hear from Paul Doherty
chief technology officer of Accenture
[Applause]
the ultimate power of the Google cloud
platform is the acceleration of
innovation that you get digital
transformation is the big thing that's
happening in companies right now energy
utilities travel financial services
insurance communications media
technology all have some of these common
needs that we think we can solve
together every exchange you have with
customer needs to improve trust and it
all it takes is one bad interaction to
destroy trust that's where the Accenture
Google Cloud partnership comes into play
bringing together the industry expertise
and solution capability of a company
like Accenture with a powerful
technology platform of Google and
accelerating customer solutions and
bringing a new platform for innovation
to customers who are looking to drive
your business faster
[Music]
please welcome david klein chief
technology officer viacom a media
company working so closely with us David
[Music]
David welcome thank you for coming
why comma is delivering an incredible
number entertainment me experience this
billions of people everyday how are
using Google cloud to make that possible
so if I come creates and distributes
iconic content across the globe
Paramount Pictures Nickelodeon MTV Det
Comedy Central Austin this TV throw
Viacom Digital Studios
Pluto TV which was a new acquisition
experiences like the BT experience live
events Casey A's Kids Choice Awards and
then what we do on the daily events the
Trevor Noah show the daily show what we
do for things like paw Patrol and
animation so all of that leads up to a
great user experience and iconic
memories with that said Google Cloud
very much enables us to look at a whole
bunch of fine points security
reliability scalability enabling us to
take that content and enrich it MLA I
and how do we at the end of the day
enable the consumer experience to be
awesome by being on your clap why will
we the right partner for you so that
starts with partnership just from the
word you said I would tell you to begin
with your sales group your engineers
your DevOps teams your ml and AI teams
we're very much broad in knowledge but
also came in with the understanding of
really wanted to understand what Viacom
needs what's our strategy what are we
looking to accomplish how are we looking
to accomplish that and that happened the
Google tools sit on top of us and make
sure that we're enabling and growing
with it so what I would say to begin
with understanding our culture Viacom's
got a rich and very traditional culture
that is based on creativity and that
creativity was enabled by Google coming
in and really taking some time in
thinking about what can we do with you
what can we do with things in the music
industry what can we do around girls who
code which I'm a big advocate of with
women in engineering and what goes on in
the space of an inequality of DevOps and
how we help balance that and then really
then came in and really helped us
understand some of the things you've
done around
search around metadata around enhancing
that content and really coming together
on a joint opportunity on how we can
take our content and really enrich it as
I mentioned earlier that's our
intellectual property taking that
content putting it up in the cloud
making it accessible knowing that it's
safe knowing that it's got the proper if
you want to call ability to enhance and
entice our consumers is a big piece and
we've really just gotten started on the
journey but we are so very excited and
very much looking forward to a future
thank you very much for coming and thank
you for your partnership thank you
it's a pleasure lastly retail in
industry where Google helps so many
organizations we've introduced a number
of new products targeted for retail the
abilities search products using images
recommendations ecommerce hosting
ordering things online with the digital
shopping assistant demand forecasting
and others we've also built retail
healthcare and financial services
solutions specifically with Deloitte and
let's hear from chief executive officer
of Deloitte Janet fountain what I hear
from customers about the Deloitte and
Google cloud Alliance is that they love
the richness of the Google technology
the very very deep industry and domain
expertise that Deloitte brings to bear
our focus on the end customer and
frankly our ability to execute and
execute aggressively financial services
healthcare government and retail are the
places where we believe we can
collectively have the most short-term
impact centered in and around where s AP
is going as a critical dimension where
customer and marketing analytics are
going as a critical dimension and then
all things that surround those domain
the Deloitte and Google Cloud Alliance
allows us to address both the great
optimism and enthusiasm about the market
as well as the anxiety and worry about
can we keep pace with what's to come and
its most fundamental that's really what
it's all about
a customer in the retail industry that's
working with us to deliver analytics and
insight in new ways is Proctor and
Gamble please welcome guy Perry chief
data and analytics officer of Procter &
Gamble guy
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
what business problems is Google cloud
helping Procter & Gamble wins at Procter
& Gamble our products touched the lives
of billions of consumers around the
world every day brands that many of you
know of Tide Swiffer Pantene Gillette
all of those brands at their core
require data analytics as part of our
digital transformation journey we're
really looking at digital transformation
as a way to get data as a way to disrupt
our business and better improve the
lives of consumers now to power an
enterprise like Procter & Gamble there
are a lot of data signals that we're
looking to integrate and harmonize
including purchase information supply
chain consumer data on the media social
media channels as well as demographics
and whether there's more data out there
for more sources than you and I ever
would have imagined when we first
started our careers it's very exciting
but also a great challenge to scale for
an enterprise of our size last year we
were looking for an agile leading-edge
platform on which to collect organize
and analyze data what we really were
looking for is a deep technical
capability to scale to our needs and so
we leveraged our experts to do an
analysis of all the cloud providers
including Google cloud PNG has a very
thoughtful cloud strategy and based on
since the successful technical pilot
we're excited to have GCP as one of our
strategic cloud partners why did you
choose GCP what was some of the reasons
you chose us
so at P&G we have a very deliberate data
strategy and we want reliable granular
data to be integrated and harmonized and
powered by algorithms to inform and
democratize the data for decision makers
around the world and in some cases in
real time so what this means is we need
to have data loading and prep at scale
and data warehouse is built and priced
to handle the the scale and the future
data loads that we need to process
including very low hassle management and
overhead we also want to apply the best
ml and AI on top
of the data to deliver what we call our
superiority strategy which is
irresistible superior product and
package brand communication in-store
execution everything aimed at delivering
value to our consumers and customers so
while we're in the early days of our GCP
relationships we found that in the
Google cloud and one last thing the core
of what PNG stands for is passion for
consumer understanding and focus and
even an IT we're looking for providers
who understand that about us and are
wanting to work with us on those terms
and we found that in the Google Cloud 2
so we're looking forward to sharing many
successes together Thomas thank you very
much guy thanks so much having me
so what an amazing two days so many
product announcements to bring you this
technology we at Google are committed to
expanding our go-to-market teams work
with partners and deepening our industry
and product focus you'll hear a lot more
from us that events throughout the year
today I wanted to thank you all our
customers and partners for the amazing
time you've given us at Google in
supporting you and our vision for
transformation
[Music]